[Music]
on this Thursday night a verdict in a
deadly attack on a Muslim family in
Ontario Nathaniel belman guilty of
murdering the offal family who were out
for a walk what relieved relatives say
still needs to be done to address hatred
we pray that we can move forward to
build a decent and just
Society an Israeli Canadian killed by
Hamas is laid to rest her views would
not have changed she would have been
even more steadfast why Vivian Silver's
calls for peace endure as Israel's Army
continues to search gaza's largest
hospital Plaza proposed settlement in a
multi-million doll lawsuit by Canadian
Veterans for disability
benefits and Panda diplomacy is back why
China says it's sending new Bears to the
US global national with Donna frez good
even evening and thanks for joining us
there is a verdict in a case that
gripped the entire country more than two
years ago the upol family who were out
for a walk in London Ontario were run
over by a pickup truck the man driving
it told police he was out looking for
Muslims to kill that day today a jury
found Nathaniel veltman guilty on four
counts of first-degree murder and one
count of attempted
murder he intended to instill fear and
Terror in our
hearts however this wasn't just a crime
against the Muslim Community but rather
an attack against the Safety and
Security of all
Canadians prosecutors called it an act
of terrorism the first time terrorism
laws have been argued in front of a jury
in a first-degree murder trial in this
country our Jeff simple was in the
courtroom when the verdict was read
Jeff Donna the judge had asked people
inside the packed courtroom to restrain
their emotions but it proved to be too
much the victim's friend friends and
family members gasped and burst into
tears as the jury read out their verdict
Nathaniel veltman guilty of first degree
murder for the first time since the
murder trial began almost 3 months ago
family members of the victims spoke
publicly describing feelings of grief
and relief the enduring grief trauma and
the Irreplaceable void left by the loss
of multiple Generations has pierced us
profoundly four members of the afol
family were killed their 9-year-old son
seriously injured and orphaned when
Nathaniel veltman plowed into them with
his truck the 22-year-old found guilty
of four counts of first-degree murder
and one count of attempted murder while
this verdict does not bring back our
loved ones it is a recognition by the
justice system that the perpetrator of
these henis crimes is indeed a murderer
and a terrorist veltman was indeed
charged with terrorism it's the first
time a jury in Canada has ruled on a
terrorism case involving first-degree
murder and where the alleged terrorist
is a far-right white nationalist that's
really important because when there are
a variety of different type of extremist
movements that are motivating people to
commit acts of terrorism and it's
important that those um individuals are
are understood to be terrorists
representatives from the local Muslim
Community who attended the trial say the
attack left its members terrorized
questioning whether they needed to hide
their Muslim faith we are living in a
time in which there has been an
increased number of incidences that are
islamophobic uh and and hate-based but
today is is an important step in terms
of providing a deterrent for anyone who
feels or thinks that uh this can happen
uh without any consequence to today is a
clear resounding message to say
absolutely not I want the world to know
why I did what I did just hours after
his arrest veltman told police he
intended to commit a terrorist attack
though he later tried to claim he was
not in his right mind due to drug use
and mental health issues as the ruling
was read out veltman slouched in his
chair expressionless staring at the
floor as he was led out of the courtroom
well he's in shock his lawyer says
they'll now consider an appeal there are
live issues that uh perhaps should be
resolved by an appellant tribunal it's a
first jury trial on terrorism so that's
going to make it interesting in and of
itself now the jury didn't actually
clarify whether veltman is guilty of
deliberately planning the attack or
committing terrorism or both either one
of those would have resulted in a
first-degree murder conviction that's
something the judge is expected to
address in the sentencing hearing next
month first-degree murder carries an
automatic sentence of life in prison
with no chance of parole for at least 25
years Donna Jeff simple in Windsor
Ontario tonight thanks in California a
Canadian man has been found guilty of
attempted kidnapping and assault in the
violent attack on the husband of former
US House speaker nany Pelosi 43-year-old
David deap faces up to 50 years in
prison 83-year-old Paul Pelosi was
bludgeoned with a hammer and suffered a
fractured skull dap originally from
British Columbia broke into the Pelosi
San Francisco Homeland last October
claiming he wanted to kidnap Nancy
Pelosi she wasn't home toap said he hit
Paul Pelosi in a moment of Despair
because his larger plan was thwarted in
Gaza the UN says disease and hunger is
spreading through the Gaza Strip staff
at the Indonesian Hospital in Northern
Gaza say they can no longer operate on
seriously ill patients the hospital's
Chief says more than 40 patients have
been left in the reception area because
there are no resources and practically
no doctors the Israeli Army Army sent
soldiers back to alifa hospital today
where it claims Hamas has its command
and Control Center and late today
released video it claims is a Hamas
tunnel shaft under that hospital video
Global News cannot verify Mike Armstrong
reports the sign on the door says baby
girl Israeli Defense Forces released
this video Thursday of what appears to
be a child's bedroom in Northern Gaza it
also appears to have been used to to
hide
weapons the IDF claims it recovered
Rockets rifles ammunition and
explosives the Israeli military also
released an audio recording it says is
between two Hamas Fighters One says he
has rockets and asks how they should be
delivered he's told the person should
move them in a baby
stroller but this may be what the IDF
was most eager to find and show off
Israeli soldiers says it's the entrance
to a tunnel outside a building in the
shifa hospital
complex IDF spokesman Daniel hagari says
military engineers are inspecting the
tunnel but that they also found others
in addition to shifa hagari says tunnels
have been discovered at the rantisi
hospital and alud hospital they appear
to be complex systems he says branching
off in different
directions now hagari says the IDF wants
to show the proof as soon as possible
but that it's a slow and dangerous
process soldiers have to worry about
booby traps and are at times having to
work while taking
fire Hamas Thursday again denied it has
tunnels under hospitals still insisting
any evidence found is planted and that
there is no Hamas control center under
alifa we avoid all the hospitals all the
time there has been a very public battle
for public opinion both sides have been
putting out
videos this was a pickup found Thursday
the IDF says was supposed to be used in
the October 7th attacks but didn't go it
was still packed with
weapons but it's the tunnels that Israel
has said were the reason it had to go
into Northern Gaza so
hard it says its Special Forces took out
two Hamas leadership groups in tunnels
this week those are images it wants to
show
but the IDF says when it finds tunnels
where hos Fighters have left it has to
worry about explosives and when it finds
tunnels where hos Fighters are still
there it has to use explosives usually
leaving them severely damaged Donna all
right M Armstong in Jerusalem thanks the
Israeli military says it has found the
body of one of the more than 200
hostages taken by Hamas in a building
near El shifa Hospital Yehuda Vice was
65 years old she was being treated for
cancer when she was taken captive from
her home on the beeri kibutz on October
7th Israel did not specify how she died
Canadian Israeli Peace activist Vivian
silver lived in that same kabut it was
thought she was taken hostage too but
this week it was confirmed she was
killed by Hamas in her home on October
7th the 74-year-old was born in Winnipeg
she moved to Israel in 1974 and that's
where her funeral was held today loved
ones gathered to remember her passion
for using friendship and cooperation to
try to bridge The Divide between
Israelis and Palestinians here's teria
isri viven silver dedicated her life to
peace but did not live to see it
happen I still can't accept it says her
son hen zyen the fact my mother will
have grandchildren she will never meet
for more than a month Silver's family
believed she was taken hostage and still
alive her heartbroken brother spoke at
her funeral I will miss hearing her
voice Neil silver says his sister was
always an idealist even as a girl
growing up in Winnipeg just looking
around today see some the the types of
people became religious secular
Vin uh she touched so many lives
she founded the group women wage peace
promoting Partnerships between Jews and
Arabs silver would often Drive sick
Palestinians from Gaza to hospitals in
Israel she was so involved in trying to
help and it's just
so
unfair gadir hanni is a member of women
wage peace and an Arab Israeli she was
one of the last people silver spoke to
shalom believed in peace and working
together Silver's brother says most of
the people on kabut Berry where silver
lived were left leaning but some of the
survivors now question whether there
will ever be an end to the violence
viian wouldn't have been her views would
not have changed she would have been
even more steadfast believing that there
are that there are people on the other
side who really do
want the same thing that the people on
this side want family and friends say
silver would tell those in doubt there
is no way to peace peace is the way
teria isri Global
News the RCMP has responded to a global
news investigation that found hundreds
of people connected to the Iranian
regime are in this country threatening
the lives of some Canadians in a
statement the RCMP say it received
reports of foreign interference being
committed by or at the direction of the
Islamic Republic of Iran this week
Global News reported upwards of 700
people linked to the regime are living
in Canada the federal government has not
given a clear answer as to whether it
will designate Iran's revolutionary
guard Corps as a terrorist entity the
prime minister's agenda for the Apec
Summit coming up why support for Ukraine
will be a top
priority the presidents of China and the
United States spent hours together
yesterday meeting in San Francisco their
first face-to-face talks in more than a
year and when they emerged there were
signs of a softening in the testy
relationship they agreed to resume
Communications between their militaries
Xi Jinping said we need to build more
bridges and pave more roads between each
other later Biden was asked if he still
believes she is a dictator something he
called him back in June Biden said yes
well that got a firm rebuke from China's
foreign Ministry which called it
extremely wrong and irresponsible
politic iCal manipulation prime minister
Justin Trudeau is also in California and
today he met with Pacific Nation leaders
at the Apex Summit the official agenda
focused on building economic resilience
in the region but Canada has its own set
of priorities including drumming up more
support for Ukraine David Aken is
traveling with the Prime Minister David
well Donna one of prime minister Justin
Trudeau's priorities here is to remind
Pacific leaders that Ukraine remains at
war with a Pacific Nation an Apec member
and that of course is Russia Russian
President Vladimir Putin is not among
the leaders assembled here but there is
a Russian delegation at this meeting of
Pacific leaders and that delegation
would certainly be aware that in a phone
call Wednesday Trudeau promised
Ukrainian President Vladimir zalinski
that he would advocate for the Ukrainian
cause at this Summit Trudeau will argue
that pacific Nations should support
Ukraine in order to ease Global Food
insecurity and help reduce food prices
in Canada and around the world we're
seeing international events like
Russia's illegal invasion of Ukraine
which has included a devastating
blockade of global grain sources that's
denying food to the world especially in
places in the global South uh threatened
with food insecurity my foreign minister
Apec member Thailand is one of the
world's largest importers of Ukrainian
grain one reason why Trudeau had this
one-on-one meeting Thursday with
Thailand's prime minister threa tasan I
know it's been a very difficult time for
you so lots to talk about in our
bilateral relationship also lots to talk
about in the world at this time this
year as well chto in fact had 15 or
20-minute oneon-one meetings with
several leaders but only briefly bumped
into China's president Xi Jinping at the
opening photo op and it really is China
that has been reluctant to commit Apec
or any other group China belongs to to
take strong action against Russia Russia
is is um the Rogue State at the moment
um and China's walking a fine line in
the middle it has kept a strong
relationship with Russia but it hasn't
fully um aligned itself with Russian's
objectives in Ukraine last year's Apex
Summit finished with a declaration by
leaders condemning Russian aggression
but leaders went on to say that Apec
wasn't the place to do anything about
that we'll see if Trudeau can change
that view this year Donna all right
David Aken in San Francisco thanks and a
final note after a two- decade pause it
appears so-called Panda diplomacy
between the US and China is back on
track president Xi Jinping hinted China
will send new pandas to the US calling
them envoys of friendship China loans
pandas to more than 20 countries with a
first ones arriving in America in
1972 still ahead Canadian veterans on
the verge of a legal
[Music]
victory
the federal government has reached a
proposed settlement agreement in another
class action lawsuit filed by Canadian
veterans if approved in court the
settlement could see Veterans Affairs
paying out money owed and disability
benefits to more than 300,000 veterans
or their survivors Heidi petek explains
what the case is all
about final settlement agreement an
agreement between lawyers representing
veterans receiving disability benefits
and the government Department
responsible for them they incredibly
slow
Learners um and I think that's any
government bureaucracy you know it's so
big so combersome this is actually the
second time veteran Dennis manou has
taken otta watch a court the first was a
battle over military pension clawbacks
settled for almost $880 million in
2013 now a decade later this suit could
see the government pay out up to $817
million to former members of the
Canadian armed forces and RCMP the
veterans AB budsman identified an error
that took place uh from 2003 to 2010 and
uh the government of Canada at that time
agreed to make a corrective payment that
first error flagged 5 years ago but then
lawyers figured out Ottawa didn't
include the interest in its corrective
payment and discovered two other
accounting errors on top of that lawyer
Daniel Wallace says that means as many
as 330,000 veterans could be owed more
the agreement still has to reach final
approval by a court in Ottawa a hearing
for that is scheduled for December 18th
and it will take until sometime next
year until claims by those affected will
start to be processed that includes
claims from Estates of veterans who have
died in the years it has taken to settle
the matter these are our honored Heroes
of our country and their families and
all they're asking for is dignity and
respect and you would encourage the
government and their departments to do
the same thing like Legacy the
importance of um standing up for what's
right man says his Focus has been on
healing from the injuries he suffered in
his service now and he hopes this case
will be the last he'll have to take on
for its part the Department of Veterans
Affairs would only say that veterans
quote deserve our greatest recognition
and respect Heidi pic global news
Austria Lake Nova
Scotia next the seismic science behind
Iceland's l volcanic
eruption in Iceland people are waiting
and watching the Earth beneath their
feet there have been hundreds of small
earthquakes and authorities suspect a
volcano could erupt at any moment Eric
senson explains what is happening and
where it might
lead it was obvious as roads split apart
this week that grindvik had to be
evacuated we just came home to to get
some stuff they have about 5 minutes to
get their belongings and then we go to
the next house it's now a ghost town
3,800 people and now there's no one
living here from 3,800 to zero they've
discovered that grindvik sits above a
long Subterranean intrusion of molten
rock this intrusion now sits just below
the Earth's surface so a molten sheet of
magma over a distance of 15 km Fishers
have opened up all over town but where's
the lava it is a land of ice above and
fire below where residents have to be
prepared you can almost imagine the
signs that might pop up only in Iceland
with its unique geology Iceland is a
Marvel where the planet's tectonic
surface meets the molten interior two
great forces first the Mid-Atlantic
Ridge where the North American and
Eurasian plates are pulling apart
Iceland straddles that Ridge as it runs
through the North Atlantic the second
force that has created this island of
lava is a hot spot one of the world's
largest a plume of magma from deep in
the Earth's mantle now pushing
underneath the rikus peninsula and these
forces are not always on the same
timetable since 2021 the nearby fagal
fielt volcano has regularly sent lava
flowing but right now nothing visible
sometimes this molten rock comes up to
the surface but these are separate
processes this is a rifting event this
is a plate motion event and plate
motions occurs in with fits and studs
and they jerk apart sometimes there were
more than 1500 earthquakes just the last
2 days below the magma is moving but
it's heavy and could remain up to a
kilometer deep all the way to the ocean
I hope it starts out in the ocean it
would be great to get a new island and
the entrance to the harbor will be
better earthquakes and volcanoes
together or separately icelanders never
know exactly when they just have to be
ready Eric senson Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna FZ thanks for
watching Jeff simple will be here at the
anchor desk tomorrow and I will see you
again next week our final note is a
tribute to Carl tromble lead singer of
the Quebec band L cowboy fangon who has
died at the age of 47 folk rock band has
been a staple of the kbec qua music
scene for about 30 years trumbl was
diagnosed with prostate cancer in 2022
when he played his last show to a
sellout crowd this
[Music]
summer